when my career was just getting going uh
and i was a speaker uh which by the way
was not
my chosen career i fell into it um
uh there is a i forgot the name of the
organization i think it's called the
meeting planners association of america
something like that where basically all
the people
from all the corporations and
conferences who hire the speakers like
that's their job
they have their own conference and so to
get invited to this thing
is like it's like american idol like
yeah
like if you do well you get a career for
the rest of your life because everyone
in the room will want to hire you for
their conferences for the rest of years
and if you if you bum they all know who
you are and you will have no career
right like that's
like i've done this a bunch now i'm you
know i'm
relaxed on stage now you know i got this
you know
and like this is one of those events
that makes every speaker nervous
and uh and it's in this cavernous
place ironically it's like the worst
venue it was like
it echoed so you'd stand on the stage
talking you could hear yourself
anyway during my talk i'm doing start
with why
back in the early days i got this you
know
done this a million times and don't know
what happened i lost my train of thought
okay i i know this i've been through
this from before
so i went quiet you usually find my
place
and then i pick up again like i know how
to do this i've lost my train of thought
before
i went quiet and nothing happened like
nothing
came into my mind i had nothing and
now i panicked and as soon as the panic
sets in
now now all rational thought disappears
and now i start sweating and my heart
starts pounding
and i got nothing i got nothing and i
look at my pad and i look at the
audience and i look at my pad and i look
at the audience
and then i turn to them and say have you
ever had that
feeling where you forget what you're
talking about
and everything collapses your hearts and
your stomach your
hearts pounding you start sweating your
hands get clammy
and sheer panic and they're all smiling
i said
i'm having that right now i said
i said and i gotta tell you it feels
fantastic i said because i do this so
much
sometimes i forget to be present and i
said right now
i feel completely alive i said i feel
totally present
and totally with this it's as much as i
is as crazy it is
this is amazing i said
okay i need someone's help can somebody
please tell me what i was just talking
about because i
do not know what i was talking about and
they all erupted in applause
i got more applause for that
than for the actual speech
but the point is the point is
is is that in every silver
in every cloud there is a silver lining
in everything that happens to us
there is goodness